I am paused with indecisiveness and
overwhelm right now
yeah I know follow me on Twitter at
Connor Franta how dare you look who's
here what's up oh oh it's Connor Oh me
what a disguise I know we just record an
episode of not too deep we're dead you
guys should go listen to after you watch
this wonderful wonderful challenge on
soundcloud or itunes we learn a lot
about comments about a lot of ASMR yeah
target [ __ ] all the hits maybe the most
educational episode of the podcast I've
ever had just started out there is still
some knowledge I think it is it truly is
your thing in a very creative to be very
intelligent
it's my thing but today we're getting
into the holiday spirit we're doing the
greatest gift challenge and we have so
much stuff in front of us yes before
they were just throwing stuff on the
table some people like ASMR other people
get off on target hauls no here you go
what what's gonna happen is we have a
bunch of youtubers names on note cards
in this Santa hat we're gonna pick out a
youtuber and then from there Connor and
I have two minutes to try and create
what we think is the greatest gift for
ever and then you guys in the comments
let us know whose gift you think is the
greatest gift for that youtuber me
deciding for me I'm going to allow you
to choose the first you to be like oh it
is a very difficult piece of paper to
unfold Oh Oh cuz it's a sticky note
that's tape do it oh you got prank
ah combust yeah
Troye Sivan I'm I literally just read
your wave of panic I don't know what to
do again
Jack you tell us when are you mark yeah
get set go um oh my god god oh my god oh
god oh my little II don't know where to
go oh yeah I have an idea you have an
idea I don't I'm just folding we have 2
minutes 30 seconds in 30 seconds
laughter like this tape shut up mother
effing yeah no no I'm thinking while I'm
making
yeah oh wow nope oh [ __ ] oh this is all
about one minute
all right left oh my god this is not
this challenge is fun
and gift giving around the holiday
season is great my god well um 30
seconds left oh my god their protection
I wish I had a hmm no this isn't it
where is a marker god dammit where's the
tape oh my god oh my god on time have a
second we clearly don't play by the
rules on half a second okay um half a
second please explain your gift to try
you see this beautiful bowl of avocado
here is paired with this nice collection
of chips yellow corn tortilla chips
so it's chips and guacamole look I even
got the pit inside you're on the Connie
you did god dammit I wasted a whole ball
of yarn for this I would die to get this
gift personally imagine opening a box on
Christmas I would imagine my gift to
Troy is floss because not too deep the
episode with Troye Sivan he told us that
flossing is one of his favorite things
to do oh my god she has a good memory
too and I put to trial of grace oh wait
personal details I was gonna make it a
gift box but it can also be like a piece
of art I tried to put a bow in there
that got real bad real good like his
toothbrush to parrot yeah rest and then
you can travel with this so tell us in
the comments who you think may try a
better the greatest gift chips and
guacamole or clocks that's really good
god damn I just don't - I'm so stressed
out right now I need to remember the
little things like writing my name on it
pick this round oh boy oh boy okay
yeah these are hard to open these sneaky
little thing
three to beam you've been praying mamrie
Hart
Oh guys right ah oh yes Christmas
Christmas let me go
yeah oh there's regular tape right out
of my goddamn know I need that tape oh
no no I feel really stressed out you
know me I really don't know what to do I
wait I have a cute idea
oh no don't give me some design I don't
know all right one minute what kidding
mmm this is fun making gifts for your
friends is fun no seriously where's the
tape go wait yours looks cute I hate you
30 seconds quit where's the marker no no
10 seconds 10 seconds 10 seconds 5
seconds no okay
and ha okay there we go
yours took so much thought oh my god you
ruin the play-doh come here yeah Wow Oh
get that out it's a candleholder now
welcome no it's not okay there's no
doubt that mamrie Hart likes to drink so
I made her a pimp Cup
and um but I also made beans the
matching pimp Cup
oh my god okay transition I made first I
was like you know what what is mamrie
love Mae Murray loves beans I made
things a little toy and then I was like
you know what's cute dog couple toys so
I made her a matching toys and it's two
toys for two peas in a pod love Connor
and it's so well this round you know I
feel like you giving a human's dog toys
so I made her on discriminate they're
just called toys the final round I'm
gonna let you choose founder
Flula Wow I don't even know flew that
well I know no one knows spoiler that
well you ready
no never ready but I have no idea
oh my god I know what's on your mark get
set Kwanzaa
inclusive yeah we're trying to celebrate
these I mean these don't have to be for
Christmas you can be for birthdays he's
gonna be here for this okay star general
holiday oh my god are you less stressed
by not just using yarn I'm an idiot
Oh what could I do what are you so like
al-aksa dancer cool and like very calm
about yes give me addiction 30-second
time please explain yourself isn't it
obvious
I mean this is this is flute love for
flu oh I'll see myself I made a card to
again I was so impressed with your card
or your little note the first time you
spent your two minutes just writing a
really heartfelt message to bloom Flula
does there happen to your not a flute
love for Flula oh that's great I made
Flula a fanny pack for himself
hashtag dance it says
and my [ __ ] inside we have a lot of
belts and some some letters when you
meet him fool I can be like oh you look
so good I'm at a loss for words
oh here they are this you thought mine
was thought out what is stabbing it um
okay when you win
listen koji DIY [ __ ] right now I like
are these the little holes that was oh
that was yeah a rollercoaster of emotion
it was I think I cried half way through
yeah maybe uh let us know in the
comments what gifts you thought were the
greatest gifts um practical uh make sure
you listen to the full episode not too
deep with Connor over on soundcloud or
itunes and kind of rick and they find
you across the internet they haven't
already
oh just search connor franta oh my God
we're getting arrested
we're getting arrested because we are
terrible crimes if we give our horn
whose gift
oh my god hey I think some I mean like I
would have this imagine yeah hey
cumbersome yes well you know you can't
force dance and dance I will see you
guys when would say yeah I don't know we
I went on a safari yeah its its tariff
did you go on the wine safari no I went
on a safari in Africa when I went to
Swasey oh that's a real Safari yes I
went to Malibu and drank wine and look
breasts